thank you
help from above as Rescuers lift a
pregnant woman to safety
just one of countless moments of danger
and acts of heroism playing out in
Italy's flooded Emilia Romania region
on the ground emergency workers search
for more people who may be trapped
locals say they've never seen a disaster
on this scale
I've lived here since 1979. I've seen
floods go by but I've never seen
anything like that we've never had water
here
cars lie abandoned in flooded streets
Rivers burst their Banks after half a
Year's worth of rain fell in just 36
hours a state of emergency is in effect
more than ten thousand people have had
to leave their homes
where the water is receded residents are
taking stock of the damage
volunteers are helping get the most
vulnerable to Safety in case the waters
should rise again
we've come to give a hand to try to save
people and animals the situation is
still tough tragic we hope it will
improve I don't know what the weather
forecast is
it'll take time before the region can
return to business as usual
Sunday's Formula One Grand Prix has been
canceled organizers say they couldn't
guarantee the safety of attendees
it's the second time this month the
people have died as a result of extreme
weather in Emilia Romania
meteorologists say climate change could
make them more frequent
disasters of today becoming tomorrow's
Facts of Life Vincent Monaghan Al
Jazeera